hey y'all movie retrospective time
guess what you're getting a surprise
double feature today we didn't even know
we were gonna do a double feature
we're gonna do both of them at once
[Laughter]
all right well they're kind of because
they're kind of related so like i said
like in the patreon poll galaxy of
terror uh the infamous roger corman
movie from 1981 won
and we were watching it on toby and
after it was over
the next one that came on in the
rotation
was forbidden world also produced by
roger corman and using the same sets
from galaxy of terror a lot of them so
yeah so i was like well [ __ ] man why
don't we just watch this one too because
you know we were drinking and whatnot so
uh and i said and we'll talk about both
of them because they're they're very
different movies but they do have a lot
of like the same crew and stuff
different directors and stuff that's a
very different tone
both both of them have something
different to offer it's funny how galaxy
of terror is infamous you call it
infamous i thought it was a pretty good
movie well i i say infamous because of
that uh worm rape scene yeah that's why
it's infamous this was this was the
movie this is the movie that made james
cameron
yeah and i remember seeing this [ __ ]
with me and my [ __ ] buddies down in
mississippi on the sun in the summertime
and i think it was on cinemax
and when we first saw that ad for in the
guide because we had paper guides back
then to the [ __ ] to to the show to
like showtime hbo and cinemax and
everything and cinemax i think was new i
think this one was on cinemax and
cinemax showed racial [ __ ]
well they yeah they didn't call it skin
and max for nothing yeah
showed up on it and it would have it was
like new movies and this and that it's a
galaxy of terror and it's and it's it's
it had aaron moran who was the girl from
[ __ ] happy days yeah
yeah we hadn't seen her in a long time
cut several years that that that series
had been gone and it said nudity sexual
sexual situations and we go oh they're
gonna [ __ ] they're gonna she's
breaking it off she's breaking it off
naked yeah we so we thought we thought
they were talking about her so we stayed
up all night it wasn't her
she was in it but it's not what they
were talking about they were talking
about this blonde chick look like a
hustler honey she looked real good
getting raped by a big old [ __ ] alien
killer something
yeah it was just part of her dream it's
kind of the movie is a lot like
forbidden planet in a certain in a
certain way people fighting their
their id and their fears and [ __ ] which
is kind of like ahead of its time
because when we were watching it i was
kind of like this is essentially the
same premise as event horizon yeah
pretty much
uh i mean well i guess event horizon was
more like hell in space but it was the
same kind of thing where you were
fighting the thing you were mostly star
cast holy [ __ ] and you didn't know it
was all star cast at the time you're
seeing this when it when you were a kid
because these are the people at the
beginnings of their careers
i mean they got [ __ ] sid hag is in it
yes sid hang is in it [ __ ] before you
know who sid haig is and he's doing sid
hey type [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] like
his [ __ ] blows again
he's doing all that kind of [ __ ] and he
just and he plays this badass dude who
i live and died for the crystals
and it was that was that she was
impressed it was like crystal throwing
star type things are they taking any
other weapon but it was part of it they
don't do a lot of uh of backstory or
character which is perfect perfect for
the movie like just don't explain
anything you can let it put it in there
and then he's like and he's just
crystal's breaking his buddy go i got
you man he's oh he's all broken about it
you don't have to explain nothing about
it you know i mean just it's like we get
it we let you
they're letting your imagination go with
this
but this movie
it didn't look very good on the
television screen crt tv
and i never saw this in the theater
seeing it now in hd on a [ __ ] decent
on on a decent [ __ ] tv you're like oh
this this movie's badass
it looks really nice it looks really
good it
exchanged cameron's work he's making an
alien rip-off movie that is so good they
give him alien to aliens
and when you watch this movie it's got
imagine aliens two
being done with kind of like terminator
one
technology you know from terminator one
budget
probably less than terminator one maybe
oh i'm sure
but he gets the job done man [ __ ] the
interiors look good the exteriors look
good
good score uh
decent flow of the movie good writing
you got [ __ ] freddy krueger the dude
who plays freddy krueger robert england
robert england's in it he fights himself
good special that's one of my favorite
scenes actually
good special effects some [ __ ] hot
blonde [ __ ] gets raped by a goddamn
alien [ __ ] caterpillar old dude gets
eaten up by damn tentacle [ __ ] vipers
going down in the damn hole they're
ripping off alien at certain parts
but it's working it's working and
then there's like
you found out that the earth is being
controlled by this supernatural master
he's kind of like the [ __ ]
sith lord or something he's called the
planet master planet master he's in
charge of the whole [ __ ] deal and he
controls all the everything and makes
sure peace is raining on the planet and
he's ordering [ __ ]
astronauts to go and investigate [ __ ]
they get to this planet and then when
they're showing the planet man it looks
a lot like a cross between
lv 426 and [ __ ] the planet from
prometheus and it's like they just
they're so you can see where
the alien franchise and all the
spin-offs where they
ripped off a lot of the [ __ ] actually
came from this movie
yeah although like yeah it's kind of
like
obviously roger corman king of the bees
yeah uh he made a lot of questionable
films sure but i don't think and i
haven't like checked this but of all the
films he made which was a lot um i don't
think a single one of them made uh lost
money and that's just because he really
knew how to stretch a dollar yeah um
like until it screamed pretty much
but he also seemed to have a really good
eye for finding really awesome talent so
what happened with this one galaxy of
terror he's like obviously alien comes
out in 1979 it's a huge deal and he's
like hey let's rip that off
so the story of this one
it's similar in the sense that we're
sending a group of ragtag astronaut
people to this other planet uh to
do like because there's a distress
caller ship's gone missing or something
like that
and so they send them there and then
they start dying in horrible ways
um but like i said it almost kind of has
like an and they do that whole thing
where one crew member
is
like uh like a spy you know what i mean
so they did the same kind of thing like
they did with the dude who plays mark
martin the martian ray wallston ray wall
street that dude's in everything yeah
it's just an all-star cast pretty much
yeah but like i said they do a different
thing with it because and i guess that's
kind of cool because it gives you more
leeway to have everybody killed in a
different and splashy kind of way yeah
uh because
it's essentially your own fears killing
you and so like i said the cook he's the
cook on the ship right ray ray walton
ray wilson and uh so he's the one that
ends up being
the he's actually the planet master and
doesn't he say in disguise
planet masters in disguise but yeah so
but uh yeah so he basically says the
planet they come to which is called what
morganthus morgan is i think it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter does it matter
um is
wasn't it made it was made as like a
game planet so it's very star trek um
it's made us like a game planet for the
children of some lost civilization like
they're all gone now yeah they're
they're they're putting and they're and
they're supposed to like confront their
fears so
they're doing too much exposition at
that point they should have just let
that [ __ ] be but there is some okay go
ahead
i'm just saying sometimes when they add
information or backstory to it it
diminishes it
do you notice that yeah well although
like i said a lot of what they said yeah
but i like the concept of this one
though because it's you you got to give
him credit like roger corman like i said
he's notoriously cheap and try to like
do all these knock-off pictures and
stuff like that but
you know and you know very famously
we're going to shoot like three movies
on the same set and we're gonna you know
we're gonna shoot in four days or
whatever we don't have a script or
whatnot which is what happened with the
next one but um it's it's just kind of
like they do actually seem to put an
effort into
they could have just very easily made a
direct alien rip-off which they kind of
did they kind of did but then they added
their own [ __ ] to it too like i said
they added the psychological aspect of
everybody getting killed by their own
fears
uh which like i said made for more
interesting deaths so they could put
more gore in there
uh than alien has yeah so this movie
doesn't make total sense either no it's
not at all all right like
at one point the captain who's
she's a hottie you know she's probably
about i think she was supposed to kind
of be like ripley oh grace sabrisky she
played the captain i was like oh my god
i'm just used to seeing her older and
like all the david lynch movies but yeah
she was in this town she's maybe 40
something in this but she's [ __ ]
looking good they're trying to make her
look older they like great great great
hair you know
and anyway
she goes outside the airlock and [ __ ]
gets killed
when it hits her boom she blows up it
didn't make much sense because everybody
else is outside not wearing a spacesuit
why are why aren't they boring now when
i looked it up on wikipedia it said that
she blew up because she was in the
airlock and fired her weapon inside the
airlock and that's what blew her up so
she wasn't outside okay
but it makes better sense than everyone
else walking around outside not blowing
up and her being the only one that blows
up yeah
okay so because we were talking we were
talking about why the hell did that kill
her although i didn't catch that because
it happened so quickly and like on a
monitor because then somebody watched it
like on a monitor and i was like wait
what just happened she just exploded
what the hell's that about corman
understood the market yeah okay uh he
knew that a lot of [ __ ] was going vhs
and then there was damn
uh
vhs tapes were still real expensive at
this time but i think that they knew vhs
prices would come out and there'd be
rentals and [ __ ] he was just trying to
make a bunch of material and cable was
coming out too so i think he knew that
this this did make four million dollars
at the box office on a one million
dollar budget okay that's what it cost
to spend it to make so he made a lot of
profit on this yeah but
the he
this was he knew that this movie would
probably for most people that were
watching this movie were not going to be
seen in the theater he made money most
likely by
renting it out to cable all right and
then later
probably vhs rentals
probably made a pretty good amount but
that was included in
what the profit was cookies trying to
get we'll give you
eat later poop she's going to give me
some little she's like no i don't i
don't understand later
[Laughter]
okay i'll give you something she's like
come on i'm just going to make noise
the whole chef yep but he knew
that so now she's getting the other one
the other box
he knew that
this was going to be teenage boys
watching this yeah all right and
everything is written accordingly
and of course there's going to be new
gratuitous nudity this is pre-internet
pornography
era yeah you know now it's so easy you
kids today with faces
easy access to internet porn where you
can just like turn around and like get
on your phone anytime you want teenage
boys
those teenage boys who weren't supposed
to be in the theater basically
they were in there anyway though okay
they needed to get their fix and they
were going to show them some titties and
there's a lot of [ __ ] in every corman
sci-fi movie i've seen has it in it
um at least from this era
but uh
it's uh
the thing is that makes this movie
different
is that you could tell that corman
actually put effort into this one
they spent a lot of money on these sets
these sets
look like it sets from aliens
in a way
they reproduce that [ __ ] same kind of
tone now the filters that they're using
don't kind of make it look
all that
i just gave you some of that i just gave
you some of that
[Laughter]
you can tell that the sets are cheap but
they they get away with it okay it looks
good
all right um you can tell it's kind of
made out of junk
but that's what you do anyway when you
make a set like this you know just
watching
junk and [ __ ] radiator [ __ ] stuff
and [ __ ] fill air filters from your
you know from your [ __ ]
air conditioner and [ __ ]
i was gonna say though that i think i
mean obviously that's a credit to james
cameron now james cameron had worked on
battle beyond the stars right that came
out before this one i think yeah that
looks good too and then prior to that
like because he'd always been kind of
like second unit director he's second
unit director on this and i think he's
the production designer and you can
definitely tell
that whoever did the you know the
production design on this is going
places because
as cheap as this movie
was it doesn't really look all that
cheap no when you're looking at it you
can see where certain design where
certain concepts came from that were
used in aliens
it's a ripoff of alien wand it is but
he's kind of
made improved it in a certain way
and you're seeing the beginnings of
aliens too the shots the way
uh
you know control consoles are made the
way rooms are separated the doors the
ceilings that you can see where
where it where this where the interiors
and exteriors from aliens came from and
they came from this movie i'm and it
looks good man it looks really good it
would have looked even better if you use
the right filters and the same things
that you saw that they used in aliens to
make them look a little more high-end
you know to hide some of the
imperfections some of the imperfections
you can see because it's kind of kind of
clear you know it needed to be a little
more ambiguous maybe some you know
water dripping and bad lighting and
you know [ __ ] mist which you see that
in in aliens you know when they're
walking around those compounds because
you know there's water dripping through
you know make them look a little more
rustic and more like a real location
this does kind of look like a set but it
looks like a good set it looks good i
mean i really like i was uh quite
impressed by the shot where they're kind
of like the crews all walking along
those
sort of a little wide whatever the [ __ ]
they are like a little bridge type of
thing yeah and like down this down the
side is like all these long walls that
are almost kind of like these
what i don't even know what you call
that almost somebody in the pyramid yeah
yeah yeah like it almost kind of looks
like a weird like wrought irony type of
stuff like pattern sort of stuff and it
looks really cool some kind of power
generator or something when you look at
the pyramid i'm going man that looks
like the damn reactor on on
the reactor on lv 426 on the damn aliens
too you know the reactor is like a
pyramid with the top cut off yeah it's
that same thing basically it's just
looks like an ancient ruin looks like it
got veins and [ __ ] going it's jacked
the the pyramid is jacked it's got veins
running up yeah it looks really good
like i said i mean i've seen some higher
budget movies than this that came out in
1981 that don't look as good as yeah
they go down the top of it and you can
see that inside the pyramid is like
another pyramid it's not lit up it looks
like a grating around it it's some kind
of power generator but there's rooms in
there and
they're having these damn alien
hallucinations and being attacked by
[ __ ] and it's kind of like something out
of forbidden planet and event horizon
kind of they got they're fighting their
own fears and a lot of them don't
realize what it is that they're fighting
they think it's [ __ ] monsters or
they're fighting themselves
and they actually kind of
the dialogue is pretty good this the
story story's pretty good it's well
thought out and
you corman's trying to make he knows at
least with this movie has to be a
serious movie
something that the fans would like
you know
now he he's knowing that he's invested
money in this film and then from then
that's those same sets you can
mix them up and well yeah he did that a
lot he did that
he did that with like the edgar allen
poe films and stuff like right like in
the 60s i mean he's like hey we built
this [ __ ] why not like use it again
we'll just like redress it a little bit
yeah but you can tell this is the main
effort
this is the this is yeah this is the
first one that they made with these sets
yeah
the sets were made for this movie yeah
you could tell and then they were going
to repurpose them with even lower budget
movies after
and use shots and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
but with a different cast a cheaper cast
which yeah because the cast in this one
is like pretty much everybody is
recognizable yeah um so let's talk a
little bit about the worm rape scene
because that's kind of what everybody
talks that's what everybody remembers
from this movie
it's very famous so uh that actress's
name is taffy o'connell
okay um so was she an actress or a
hustler i'm not really sure uh t with
two a's two f's and then an e at the end
so i'm assuming that's taffy she's
smoking hot for the 80s it's that 80s
kind of nobody [ __ ] look that was the
skinny cocaine inspired [ __ ] kind of
woman that's what she's like but she is
pretty
and she's acting pretty well sure she
i don't know if she's an actress or not
or if she's a stripper or a [ __ ]
model i don't know
but she comes off as a real actress in
this
she's gets scared by seeing these dead
bodies and
she finds one of them that's all [ __ ]
up and it's got worms on it she burns it
up with her [ __ ] ray gun so she
doesn't have to look at it which they
all [ __ ] vaporize bodies as soon as
they see them even before other people
show up to see it they don't do any
analysis or anything just burn it up
it's like nope
not gonna let that sit around
yeah they're real disgusted by these
dead bodies well this that one had worms
on it you could easily tell they're the
mealworms you feed to your lizard but
it's got worms on it she didn't like
worms she was scared of yeah that's why
she ended up getting like yeah and the
fear of the worms caused one of them to
grow [ __ ] huge
you know probably 30 feet long it's just
big slimy [ __ ] it's a big old sex
worm
that's what i'm gonna call it
and it comes down the hallway and jumps
on her [ __ ] rips her clothes off and
all this [ __ ] slime coming out of it
and she's going
she's fighting and then then she starts
getting into it and then she's just kind
of like oh well wait she gets it and
then it kills her anyway
which i guess that was part of her fear
maybe her fear was that she would get
into it well initially okay so when they
first got this woman to be in the movie
initially in the script whatever script
they had
uh the worm was just supposed to
accidentally
tear off her top while it was eating her
yeah but then the producers were like uh
no if she's gonna be in the movie she
has to have a sex scene yeah so at which
point roger corman was like okay well
then we'll have the worm rape her to
death yeah and like tear all her all of
her clothes off yeah now when they first
uh kind of presented that to her she was
just like nah bro i'm not doing that but
uh they did actually get a body double
oh so it's not her um most of it's her
okay but i think like a couple of the
shots and actually they had to take a
couple bits out because when they first
like submitted this to the npa or
whatever they gave it an x rating
they said and it's weird like the shots
that they told them they had to take out
it's not what you would think it's the
two shots that they had to take out was
like two seconds maybe not even that uh
was a shot of her face looking like she
was super into it like or cuz you know
you can't show a woman like having a
good time or like an orgasm or anything
that's that's now that's not porn yeah
uh you know because she's getting raped
by a worm and also uh there was one shot
of the worm kind of like making a
humping motion yeah
uh so they took a second of that out but
honestly when we were watching it last
night on 2b
i
you you would be hard-pressed to like
find out you know to to actually know
like where they took that out because it
looks pretty
it looks pretty nasty i mean even the
way it is
i kind of remembered it you know with my
with my 15 or 16 year old brain i might
have been even younger when i saw it
when i first saw this it might have been
like 14 or something
i remembered it the scene being more
graphic and longer it wasn't it was only
a few seconds it doesn't it actually
doesn't show that much
not really you see her titties and her
legs and you see her like naked from the
side like you can see part of her ass
and and you can tell that the you can
tell that the worm is raping her it's
mostly the sound effects yes sound
and it's just kind of like and you can
definitely tell that she's like oh no oh
no oh wait you know what i mean
um so
so they didn't take they didn't take
enough of it out to like that was the
horror aspect of it i guess
so it's like that was her really
deep-seated fear she not only i mean i i
think most people are probably be scared
of being eaten by a giant worm but like
she had a specific thing she's like oh
yeah i guess it's a phallic thing she
was like afraid of like a [ __ ]
they had everything in his practical
effects that all look pretty good
joanie
[ __ ] moran she got [ __ ]
man she got real [ __ ] up got a bunch
of tentacles wrapped around her and it
squished her guts out now some of them
went went across her mouth like that
pulled on her head so much our [ __ ]
skull popped off it's called popped over
i was like poor joni look what they did
during this movie that was awful it's
good
pretty cool i forgot that that movie did
this kind of stuff and and then they all
come back as zombies later yeah they
come back i haven't
grand finale and then uh and man she
looked [ __ ] up when she came back all
day yeah yeah
and her boyfriend mustache man was real
upset it's a legit flick though
yeah it stands on its own it's good it's
it it's a good
space horror movie from its day
uh
you know if you're a fan of aliens or
alien
you know this is not in the same league
as that per se but you'll you'd
appreciate it but it's not it's it's not
far from it i mean and as far as like
rip-offs go it's not it's not in the
same like z-grade kind of thing as
something like star crash no no no this
is actually just a couple steps below
it's not it's actually not it's kind of
sleazy but not as bad as like i saw um
there's a site called oh the horror and
they have like a really long review of
this as well as a forbidden world and
they said if alien is uh you know the
sci-fi equivalent of halloween then this
is the equivalent of uh friday the 13th
yeah which actually i thought was a very
good analogy it is sleazy but it's
supposed to be and it's kind of a high
budget sleazy and honestly this one it's
it does have a lot of sleazy aspects and
like uh it's pretty gory and stuff but
forbidden world to me came across as
sleazier
and gorier yeah and more pornish more
yeah but definitely more powerful and
we will start talking about that one too
oh now
that this one is another alien rip-off
it's using some of the sets from this
movie you instantly recognize them even
some of the jackets some of the guys are
wearing the same yeah they look like the
luke skywalker jackets from the empire
strikes back yeah or the yeah kind of
they do they look star wars-y yeah
they're star wars-y
or battlestar galaxy
rip off of [ __ ] star wars yeah um
they even have desert scenes you know
it's like that might have been a little
bit nod to doon i think
i thought that as well maybe it's just
because we saw dune recently but i was
kind of thinking that like oh look
pretty sure this came out out after the
dune movie the dino de laurentiis dune
it did not because that came out in 84.
galaxy of terror came out in 81 and
forbidden world came out 80. maybe maybe
they're homaging adventures in the
forbidden zone
yeah because there was kind of like a
lot of desert-y movies yeah in a lot of
mid-seventies
rip-off type stuff
um this one is
kind of like alien mixed with like a z
kind of like the blob
yeah i was thinking the blub the thing
and
almost maybe like uh
kind of like a zombie movie
it doesn't have any zombies in it but it
just kind of feels kind of like
this shows a lot of dead bodies from
people that are kind of being dissolved
and they kind of look like it's very
gooey this movie is very gooey now um
this
was also not a bad movie it was
watchable
okay oh it's a lot lower budget
you got two
kind of z grade hustler honey type
actresses in there and they just
they just get their money's worth out of
them they they're the same age one of
them looks one of them looks older than
the other one the other one just looks
like a teenage girl but they actually
got checked who these actresses were
they were exactly the same age
the uh the other ones seemed to be 10
years older and i think she was playing
the part of an older
woman it doesn't make any sense it's a
biological [ __ ]
experimentation
unit that's has a couple of teenagers in
it and it's a hot teenage girl in it
they're not teenagers but they look
pretty supposed to be tv my favorite
thing is that they're working on a
spaceship or you know a
research facility or whatever
and they're toddling around in like
tight little uh jumpsuits and those
clear lucite high-heeled shoes yeah yeah
like click and i'm just like yeah i'm
pretty sure that would be a safety
hazard like wearing those around skin
tight [ __ ] clothes
but i was just like i just laughed every
time they walked through there with this
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's like is that underwear
just a skin type
[ __ ] [ __ ] closed you know what i mean
yeah of course
and then there's
a mad scientist who's kind of like the
mad scientist out of day of the dead
kind of reminds me of that guy yeah yeah
yeah um who never changes his lab coat
his entire he just goes through the
whole thing hacking and coughing which
you find out why later there is a reason
right but he just goes through the whole
movie with blood all over his lab coat
and it cracks me up because
from the beginning like i said this
movie actually i think it's original
title is mutant and it's this research
facility and basically what they're
trying to do
is they're trying to
okay so
i'm just laughing that jenny's
explaining the movie no well we got to
talk about something i'm telling you no
but but i have to explain it to get to
what i thought was funny that's what i'm
saying i'm i'm providing context that's
what i'm doing it's just it's just i
wish you would allow me to do that
so i'm just sticking to this story how
cheesy this story is explaining it
itself okay go ahead no it's like so
they're at this research facility and
they're trying to like synthesize
some kind of like food product but then
whatever they're trying to synthesize
actually becomes sentient and actually
you know wants to start eating humans or
you know it starts eating animals like i
said it's kind of like the blob
which and they kind of like show some
[ __ ] that looks like that later yeah but
the thing that cracks me up is that at
the very beginning like they have this
dude this kind of like uh you know
muscle bound dude it's who i've seen
before and it's like bugging me and i'm
just like goddamn it i've seen that dude
in the movie it must been one that was
on mst because he looks familiar real
familiar but he comes in to clean up the
lab because they go in the lab and
there's just like dead animals
everywhere there's like dead rabbits and
[ __ ] like that and they're talking about
you know sanitation things and
everything i'm like
sanitation what it's like nobody cleans
anything the mad scientist that works on
everything is just touching [ __ ] with no
gloves on he's hacking and coughing all
over everything he's like touching
bodies and then touching food and it's
like
i was like that's gotta be a joke the
janitor comes in and uh he's about 19 or
20 yeah he's a teenager there are
teenagers
and he
has no fear of [ __ ] dangerous [ __ ]
mutant animal putting his head in there
looking at is it dude
ridiculous [ __ ] you know what i mean but
it's supposed to be [ __ ] temp is
suppose
yeah i guess what dude you're in this
[ __ ] so did they not tell them hey go
clean up the lab but hey don't open that
glass thing with that really really
dangerous animal in it that we just
accidentally made yeah this is you know
this is a bio this is a high level
biobiological experimentation lab just
walk around you know i mean [ __ ]
touch [ __ ] you know i mean just yeah no
one is wearing gloves no one's wearing
like suit like suits no nothing and it
seems to be
it seems to be that you're supposed to
laugh at this though or at least i hope
so i think i think they were laughing at
it when they were making it you know
this
because it just seemed really egregious
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then like their
idea of romance is a [ __ ] trip some
chick the little hottie chick who's i'm
not sure what job what was her job just
to walk around and [ __ ] jiggle walk
around and jiggle walk around in her
lucite high heels every time she she's a
cute little thing [ __ ] she kind of
looked like a skinny alicia silver stone
and they'd show her from the bottom like
they're also looking
and she's got the [ __ ] little [ __ ]
glasses on little [ __ ] sunglasses
wherever she goes and [ __ ]
when whenever she gets up to go
somewhere she bounces on purpose they
told look prance to the control room
yeah yeah
not enough jiggle yeah so she goes into
the damn steam bath because that's what
a girl does in the bio weapons lab you
know whatever kind of the bio food labs
and she's sitting there dude just walks
in boy you sure are beautiful you know i
guess i guess privacy and nudity is not
an issue in the future
and he's creeping he just comes off as a
creep he's like
and she's scared of him and then boom
come over here take your pants out yeah
yeah yeah just like wait hold on wait
what that [ __ ] didn't even happen in the
80s
it's just their sense of [ __ ] and she
didn't know that dude that dude was new
he was like summoned there he was
supposed to be the han solo although he
didn't really do much of anything now
that i'm thinking no
and he was like really creepy i thought
he was great yeah um i i couldn't figure
out where the story was going i mean it
did go
it did happen it did go yeah it turns
out
turns out i went when i went and checked
i checked like who wrote this [ __ ]
corman started the movie they didn't
have a script only thing he did was you
know the opening where he had the dude
in a robot that's all they [ __ ] had
and that robot was in like the first few
minutes like during the space fight and
then like mostly the robot's just kind
of standing by the wall for the rest of
people just being like hey you all right
yeah i'm okay and then they turn the
robot off again
the robot doesn't figure it into the
movie no you didn't really need the
robot they just had it it was just
because it's science fiction it looks
good it looks good the robot but it's
like i just thought of that it occurred
to me today
when i was thinking about it i said
where there was that long like five
minute sequence or whatever where where
the creepy dude
and the robot were in the ship like
coming to this research facility because
they'd been summoned there for whatever
reason and so they're like interplaying
and you know it's push that button do
you know flip that switch and oh my god
and blah blah we gotta have to like
fight all these and it's like all
exciting and then once they get to the
place the robot like i said the robot he
just turns it off all the time and it
just is standing there by the wall and
they never turned it on but they were
evidently making this story up as they
were going uh yeah roger corman was
basically like yeah you have four days
to come up with a script it's like i
don't just put this the the astronaut in
the robot in the beginning and i don't
really give a [ __ ] what you do otherwise
he's like but i kind of like the idea of
lawrence arabia and spain lawrence of
arabia in space yeah which it kind of
happened they were out in the desert
fighting the damage i haven't seen
lawrence or arabia for a long time but
i'm pretty sure there wasn't something
in there that like turned humans into
the blob yeah i mean it had it had uh
nudity and it was gratuitous
long lingering [ __ ] male gaze
oh and also well there was one part two
lesbian sea yeah i was gonna say there's
not only the part where the girl is just
naked in the sauna and the creepy dude
comes in and is like leering at her and
she's like hey what the [ __ ] and then
she's like oh never mind let's make out
yeah and then
which i was just kind of like okay
um you could tell a dude wrote this but
um but then later on there was a scene
where did like did the one like
dark-haired girl get some [ __ ] in her
hair or something like that
and they're like let's go in the shower
it wasn't really a shower it was kind of
like it just kept going whoo it was like
pulsing light
and we're both naked with radiation yeah
it's the radiation radiation bath and so
and so like the the blonde woman was
like behind the other one kind of like
combing her hands and they're both naked
of course and they're just like talking
like it's just kind of like yep
confirmed dude wrote this yeah but it
was just like
it was just like hilarious but i will
say one thing that is awesome but oh
well the monster in this oh yeah yeah
you gotta get to that looks like and
again i'm going i'm deferring to the
site oh the horror they said this looks
like a xenomorph if it was made with
paper mache yeah um also looked like
venom a little bit i thought it kind of
to me it looked like
the thing from little shop of horrors
had a baby with a black widow spider
yeah that could be made out of paper
mache yeah and maybe something and maybe
some hefty bags
[Laughter]
like you know i did like the one and it
didn't move that was the thing yeah it
was like on top of the computer bank
they would get its tentacles to move and
they would do their mouth open its mouth
would go blah blah blah but they had to
try to explain how it was going from one
place to another how it was jumping it's
so they had to do with camera angles
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious i did i
was like that's the monster they're
going with the this because the
the sets were pretty good
well the sets had been built
by james cameron and his crew they were
for the last movie they were making the
story up and it was kind of it was
entertaining i was entertained by this
one it had
unrealistic [ __ ] in some ways i think i
was a little bit more entertained by
this one than i was by galaxy
because it was much sleazier and much
funnier whereas the first one was kind
of like they had like some sleazy
elements but it was much more serious
this one was kind of goofball so there
was just all kind of like it wasn't
funny but there was a lot more crazy
[ __ ] happening in it um and i really
liked the one dude that just slowly
turned into a big pile of goo over the
course of the movie and no one like
thought to clean it up
they would just go through the lab and
just like walk around yeah there's just
like goofball over there
and it's like a crack but it looked
really good i thought that all the gooey
effects and like all that
that looks really good and so i looked
up who had done the effects on that and
it's a dude named john carl beakler
and this was his second or third movie
that he'd worked on but he went on to
work on like a lot he worked on a lot of
[ __ ] with like stewart gordon like he
worked on reanimator bride of reanimator
um he did [ __ ] mausoleum he did
transfers
uh he did ghoulies from beyond dolls
which was again a stewart gordon movie
he did uh friday the 13th seven
nightmare in elm street four
halloween four so like he went like his
wikipedia thing was like hugely hugely
long he had worked on like a lot of
movies but i'm watching this movie and
then i see this monster and i'm like why
did they go with that monster
what you know i mean they could have
i know they made them just didn't put
much like thought into me they're just
like it looks like a monster it's a
monster yeah they made up this story in
four days
i think i think this the movie would
have been better without that monster at
all and done something where it's a
contagious thing and people turning into
goo and maybe you you're fighting just
goose boars or things well because all
the goo stuff looked really good yeah i
would have focused just on that goo i
would have just dropped that monster
just not had it i mean especially for
1982 that looked that looked [ __ ]
disgusting it was great
and like
like you said
this one didn't
look as good but it was fun you could
tell that they were like it was like all
at the level of like uh
i don't know reanimator or something
it's taking place in a small area
they do go outside but they go outside
just because roger coleman said that in
fact there's a scene
where dudes fighting the damn
the [ __ ] monster and i'm like that's
where [ __ ] kirk fought the gorn
yeah i'm pretty sure pretty sure that's
where it was location right yeah i think
that was
that
rock formation looked exactly like where
the corn came down was i kind of feel
like they filmed a lot of stuff in that
location
where we did the gorn go out to the gorn
cliff yeah that's kind of oh we forgot
to mention that the blonde hottie yeah
uh how she the monster killed her by
essentially sticking one of its
tentacles up her vag and killing her and
then it came out her shoulder yeah
somehow well that was kind of like an
homage to alien one it was how they got
[ __ ] that one girl
they don't show that that's what
happened but they let you think that
because they show that that skill
and then boom and then it pops out like
over here got it with the tail and it
kind of it was so funny they go to talk
to this dangerous alien
uh while they're in their bathrobes yeah
this was after after the lesbian shower
scene yeah where they're all kind of
like talking to each other and it's like
you're talking to this giant thing
through a computer we have to
communicate with it yeah and this thing
in our bathrooms it knows english even
used the word affirmative
[Laughter]
wait a minute this thing's educated
already yeah affirmative yeah i'm going
to kill you by sticking my tentacle up
your coop yeah
it was a it wasn't kind of a fun movie
um it was i had a blast with this one
i mean i was kind of drunk when we were
watching it but the galaxy of terror is
[ __ ] a lot better though yeah now
yeah i will say galaxy of terror is a
better movie it's better made it looks
better yeah it's got great great special
effects
great special effects and it's like this
is a cheap movie and they're showing
like uh blaster effects that look really
cool they got like
better than star wars star wars was just
a bolt that would come out this in
certain angles you'd see a damn lens
flare they put lens flare uh shadows
like you've shot a [ __ ] arc
like a like a a welding arc and when it
hit a person it would light up part of
their body and it was done with that
same effect it was just a little more
meticulous they look good real good
um
the movie was really punching way above
its budget that's why they put him on
[ __ ] aliens
yeah because he really knew and he well
i think i was reading like the wikipedia
page and it was saying that he came up
with a lot of like really good like
budgetary kind of stuff on there it's
like oh we can do this and it's like
it'll be really cheap and it'll look
really good so so roger corman was like
hey this is my guy
remember when we saw this on television
i saw those blaster effects go man
that's better than star wars
in this old cheap movie because it
didn't look that good on tv on crt tv
yeah
it looks a lot better on an hdtv today
yeah which is crazy it's because you
would think that it would show up all
the flaws but it actually looks good for
a movie that came out in 81 and cost
this little to me yeah um it actually
looks really good like it looks really
decent so like i said galaxy of terror
obviously is the better movie but i'm
gonna say i think forbidden world is the
more fun movie yeah just because it was
the knockoff of the knockoff because
they're basically like well we have the
all these elaborate sets and we have
this crew here already so and we have a
few more days so let's just make another
movie
um which like i said to their credit
they could have just made another one
like galaxy of terror but they went a
different they went like a biological
type of way which i thought was cool
after we were watching this movie jenny
kind of fell asleep and it went on to
the movie after this and it looked like
another roger corman movie on those same
sets
probably it looked like it i don't
remember what it was we can go back and
look at it but yeah we'll have to go
because that's the other corner movie
and i think i saw some of the same sets
in it
well yeah well like i said that's kind
of why that's kind of why let's make it
as much as you can out of it i mean it's
yeah you can say oh it's like cheap and
everything like that but it's kind of
like well [ __ ] man you might as well you
don't have like you gotta economize
what's the name of this one forbidden
world forbidden world yeah look kind of
like
or mutant yeah kind of like we're not
ripping off forbidden planet but
forbidden world
this is how roger corman was this came
out in 81 in 1991 he recut it and
released it again as dead space as dead
space yeah and they say it's pretty much
the same movie
i thought he remade like re-shot some
[ __ ]
or i don't know if he reused i don't
know and i well i know that in galaxy of
terror some of the shots they reuse from
battle beyond the stars like i said he's
like always economizing that one
uh but i guess that's the reason that
people still remember him nowadays
because like i said the [ __ ] made like
40 bajillion movies right and uh none of
them ever lost money as long as i was as
far as i know out of the thin air yeah
well it takes a real talent because you
know any any any schmoe can like make a
cheap ass movie but it takes a real
talent to
you know actually have the foresight to
be like
to pick out people that know what
they're doing he's trying to do
he's actually doing what ed wood was
trying to do yeah
that's what i mean so it's like i know
you can [ __ ] on roger corbin all you
want but you know the dude knew what he
was doing yeah
and yeah and he knew
and he recognized like talent in other
people like i said that's why he liked
james cameron so much because james
cameron makes made everything look like
you know
amazing like on a nothing budget and in
his defense he knew
when to dish out money and when not to
yeah that too because uh galaxy of
terror had to ha had to look good if not
it would just get made fun of
and so if you're going to spend money
spend it on galaxy of terror and then
use those sets for everything they're
worth just keep [ __ ] just squeezing
them and squeezing more money out of
those damn sets in cheaper more
sleazier movies which is and honestly
i'll give forbidden world it's like the
the effects in that one are much more
like gooey and much more like gory but
those look good too yeah and like i said
it's because they got a guy that knew
what he was doing and actually like went
on and did like a [ __ ] ton of other
horror movies
they just had a a cast that was kind of
like today that would be like a cast
from an asylum film
like you know what i mean yeah just
dudes that could do it and hotties that
would take their clothes off yeah that's
you'll make money with it and that's
that it did i have to say from galaxy of
terror the worm looked really good now
they said that um that that prop that
they built obviously because you don't
have cgi back then but it weighed about
a ton and at some points while they were
doing that worm sex scene uh it almost
fell on her and she said she almost got
killed if i remember correctly when i
was reading about uh forbidden world it
it made about the same that um
that uh uh the other one did yeah galaxy
object yeah it was galaxy of terror
about i think
so that's like really for maximizing
yeah yeah so he's just [ __ ] chi-ching
so he knows
i probably done the same thing
i think i'd gone to russ meyer's way and
just put
big titty girls in there
russ meyer girls are they're just i
don't even think they're trading
strippers have we done any russ meyer
movies no we need to do something you
should read i have his uh biography it's
fascinating he was boob-centric man i
unders i feel his pain
i understand i totally understand the uh
but russ meyers would just straight up
higher strippers and [ __ ] have them
act and and they did just as well as
that well it worked out people still
watching that [ __ ] nowadays too yeah so
you know and you know
and what stripper wouldn't wouldn't
rather be a movie star
yeah i'm sure it's a lot better than
being sure
that's more notoriety and stuff and you
know
you get to show you get to act and show
your personality and [ __ ] do those
crazy ass [ __ ] stories that russ
meyers would come up with some of those
russ meyer films basically
just straight up soft core porn but some
of them did have stories you know biker
story type gangsters like i said they do
kind of try to come up with something
which like i said which is what i
respect about these two movies even
though they're both rip-offs and one is
like a rip-off of a rip-off because it's
like use reusing stuff at least they did
try to come up with
they each have their own story they're
really really different
um and they did try to come up with
something different than alien which is
what they were ripping off yeah you know
what i mean but yeah so these are both
on
2b at the moment if you would like to
watch them normally if you watch galaxy
of terror forbidden world will
automatically come out at least for us
it did yeah see this [ __ ] on tubie don't
spend any money on it
i thought they were super fun they're
super fun i would own galaxy a terror on
blu-ray yeah they're super fun that's
good i'd put you put that right next to
the [ __ ] aliens you know aliens too
you know it's a corner flick or not it's
a you know carmen and roger uh what's
his name [ __ ] not roger james
campbell james cameron
james cameron but it's it's interesting
to watch
that's james cameron
yeah yeah like the way the the sets are
yeah one of the characters names is
cameron it's actually cabrin okay i
looked it up because we thought that too
like for a long time i said are they
calling him cameron and it's like is
that an in joke but no when i looked it
up on wikipedia his name's cabrinha it's
gotta be c-a-b-r-o-n
that's got to be an in joke too maybe
yeah and i also uh have to give a
shout-out to the luxurious porn stashes
yeah a couple of the characters
porn stashes and
and boobies and good costumes and good
sets and the dudes with the the the
boobies the girls the babies don't have
porn stats i got a [ __ ] i got a shout
out to scores on both of these the
scores on both of these movies they're
both good
uh
uh galaxy of terror actually is a
[ __ ] real good score
um the [ __ ]
planet one what's it called from not
forbidden planet whatever forbidden
world forbidden world i'm getting
everything confused now forbidden world
kind of has an ultimate [ __ ] new
retro wave score to it it's a real
[ __ ] new red and like kids would jam
after that today yeah you could totally
put that and i was thinking that too
while you're watching i said oh my god
you can put this on the new ritual wave
channel with some cool like cool
graphics and [ __ ] behind it and you go
yeah that's it like a neon delorean or
something but everybody'd be like yeah
awesome
so uh and evidently at the time people
uh noted that the score was good yeah on
that one it was but yeah these these are
both uh totally worth watching super fun
uh like i said i kind of feel like
forbidden world is more fun but that's
just because it's sleazier and goopier
and boobier
[ __ ] yeah uh and has more like funny
[ __ ] in it whether the funny was
intentional or not i'm not entirely sure
in the way day of the dead was [ __ ]
funny yeah galaxy of terror is much more
serious
uh so so it's like a serious alien
rip-off but yeah like i said these are
both on to be so check them out and uh
let us know what you thought about them
so that'll do it for this
double feature movie retrospective and
we'll see you guys on the next one
bye
you